you've been in this this business since
you were a kid you yeah young yeah so
40-something years now yeah you've been
in this business yeah and you for all of
your accomplishments and you've had a
lot of them do you have you as it dawned
on you now that oh yeah
Morpheus the matrix that's gonna be yeah
that's gonna follow me probably and
there's a lot of great work there but
you know Morpheus will probably be the
character that I am best remembered for
yeah and that's wonderful
I mean yeah yeah it's great that's a
great one but the tricky part is that
people actually think that I'm Morpheus
and so they'll often say oh like they'll
see me oh Morpheus and I always say is
not my name they have an attachment to
it like I had that kind of attachment to
the Sean Connery is double-oh-seven sure
so it's an attachment that people have
and I understand but people donate ryx
movies that if someone thought that you
were Morpheus you could probably have
some fun with it
you could be like not now I'm in the mix
you know it's what's sad is that that's
what people do to me really yeah people
are like oh I'm in the matrix now
yeah no no so what's at 11:00 right you
said your while to keep a red and blue
pill
[Applause]
phone ring but the best one the best one
is is when people actually when I have
the presence of mind to say to people
you think that's air you're breathing
now just trying to go you can have a lot
of fun yeah that one's foot
you